[Music]
in this morning Saturday session Nicky
Laine Rolling Stone wrote the outlaw
country rocker songs are chased in a
streetwise modern shell that's as
unapologetic as Johnny Cash's middle
finger but there's a lot more to the
self-described Highway Queen as I found
out when we met up recently in hurricane
Mills Tennessee at the ranch of the
legendary Loretta Lynn in a blue jeans
ad on her album covers or in her vintage
clothing store in Nashville
high-class hillbilly it's obvious Nicki
Lane has an eye for fashion she dreamed
of becoming a designer but took a sudden
detour how did you go down the music
road I always say I was very heavily
motivated by spite spite towards a
country musician boyfriend
and we broke up and he went and made a
record and I was like well I'll make a
record and I couldn't play guitar you
know what I mean like even a tiny bit
[Music]
but that's never stopped her always is
really small dude
growing up in Greenville South Carolina
Nikki took the advice of her high school
social studies teacher to heart and the
first thing he wrote on the bulletin
board on the first day of school was
complacency kills and I always say that
like something in that just bore into me
what do you think up to you that sitting
around was gonna do nobody any good she
dropped out of high school and in 2006
moved to LA to pursue a fashion career
so did you just show up in California
with two grand which I spent on Ventura
Boulevard in like a week and a half
shopping were you convinced you could do
it
of course arrogance has definitely been
a positive and a negative my whole life
[Music]
she used the same perseverance to land a
record deal six months after she broke
up with that ex-boyfriend
highway Queen is her third album
co-produced with her new boyfriend
Jonathan Tyler the highway Queen is
called the highway Queen because I
wouldn't say no to any shows and the
next thing I know I haven't been home
she's played 400 gigs over the past two
years including last Memorial Day with
outlaw country legend Loretta Lynn at
her ranch in hurricane Mills Tennessee
when you started you probably wouldn't
have thought you'd be sitting with
Loretta Lynn and singing not even a tiny
bit you know Loretta the Coal Miner's
Daughter and pioneering singer
songwriter felt an immediate connection
with Nicki I mean not like meeting we
just always I felt like we always knew
each other mm-hmm why is that
I don't know we might've met another
lifetime when they met up again for
Saturday sessions the highway Queen
nearly got a speeding ticket we're going
about 90 because we were in a hurt you
know we wanted to get here and there's
two cops on the left side of the road
and Jonathan said now what are you going
to do if you get arrested on the way out
here and I was like that would be what
would happen to me I was like maybe they
can bring Loretta to the Dickson County
Jail you know maybe we can take from
Lamar